bethe O'Rourke drops out of the race
Manor Pete declares himself a top
contender and Elizabeth Warren's
dishonesty keeps coming back to biter
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is brought to
you by expressvpn go check them out it
expressvpn
dot-com / up hero again that's
expressvpn com / appear Oh alrighty so
we have a lot to get here today to hear
today on the Ben Shapiro show
forgive me if I'm slightly foggy you've
got off a 16-hour flight with my
children back from Israel to Los Angeles
that is a long flight with small
children and then my kids decided it
would be great to have like sort of a
midnight festivities they got up at 12
midnight and Rupp from 12:00 to 3:00
this has been a bit of a party but let's
jump into the news of the day so the
news of the day there our latest news
polls that show that that President
Trump is lagging behind Joe Biden so
this is the great story of the
Democratic campaign thus far the
candidates were most likely to be
President Trump are the ones who are
also the most likely to be sidelined by
the Democratic electorate so all the
people in the primaries who are doing it
the worst are the people who are most
likely to do pretty well against
President Trump with the exception of 8
O'Rourke whom we will get to in just one
second because we have to bid a fond
farewell debate go back to smoking dope
and eating Arizona in Durden all the
things that make bado bado riding that
skateboard we got to bado in a second
but there's a new poll out from Fox News
and it shows that in a hypothetical
matchup Joe Biden continues to top
president Trump nationally by 12 points
according to Fox News democratic primary
voters increasingly feel the need to
nominate a candidate who can beat
President Trump in 2020 and more thing
Joe Biden can do that than any of the
other top Democratic hopefuls in
addition while most Democratic primary
voters are satisfied with their field
more than a quarter wish they had other
options which is why there is a new snap
poll showing that Joe Biden and Hillary
Clinton if Hillary were in the race
would be running similarly at the top of
the ticket
meaning that Hillary Clinton and Joe
Biden would be running very similarly
nationally in the Democratic primaries
which is why I've said Hillary's a fool
to stay out I mean what is she brisk
occur here her incredible reputation for
victory like ooh that's the worst that
happens she runs she loses and then she
becomes a nine-time loser as opposed to
an a time what exactly does she have to
lose here Biden leads the NAM
and race with the backing of 31% of
Democratic primary voters according to
this new Fox News poll followed by
Elizabeth Warren all the way around 21%
Bernie at 19 and Pete Budaj edge all the
way down at 7% in early October Biden
was at 32 Warren Warren 22 Sanders 17
Budaj edge for Camille Harrison and Reid
younger each at 3 percent followed by
Cory Booker
tulsi gabbard and Amy Klobuchar now as I
say clobber chart would probably do
better against Trump Gabbard would
probably do better against Trump maybe
even Booker would do better against
Trump then somebody like Elizabeth
Warren Biden would do best against Trump
among all of these nominees and he is
the person who is apparently fading in
these early contests and if you look at
the polls in Iowa if you look at the
polls in New Hampshire what you see is
that Joe Biden is fading and a lot of
these state polls even though he's doing
well national he's actually up over the
past few weeks in the national polls he
actually increased his lead over
Elizabeth Warren in the national polling
he currently has an eight point eight
percent lead in the Real Clear Politics
poll average which is kind of shocking
because if you were to just follow the
polls for the last month you would have
thought okay this thing has really
narrowed for Joe Biden but it hasn't
narrowed for Joe Biden in fact precisely
the opposite as of a couple of weeks ago
Joe Biden was up only five points on
Elizabeth Warren he's now up eight
points on Elizabeth Warren there was a
point in this race where he was up at
28% in the Real Clear Politics poll
average and choose it like 23 if you go
back just even slightly before that
there was a point in the RCP average and
this point is early October where his
lead had disappeared entirely as of
October 7th 2019 Elizabeth Warren had
actually overtaken Joe Biden in the
national polling and now she seems to be
receding back to where she was now on a
state-by-state level Biden is not
running as strongly as he is on the on
the national level on the state by state
level latest poll from New York Times
Siena poll this came out October 30th
shows Elizabeth Warren at 22 Buddha
dredge at 18 a Biden at 17 and Sanders
at 19 so he's running fourth in that
poll in New Hampshire
similarly Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren are seen as the two contenders
they're a CNN UNH poll from October 27th
had Elizabeth Warren at 18 Biden at 15
Sanders at 21 Budaj edge all the way
down at 10 so all the things that make
Joe Biden attractive in a general
election matchup make him utterly
unpalatable in a primary election now
as we will see that is that is not
enough for somebody like a beta O'Rourke
right the fact is that being you sort of
have to bridge the gap so on the one
hand you have to be seen as somebody who
is capable of defeating President Trump
on the other hand you have to be seen as
radical enough to win the base Biden is
not seen as radical enough to win the
base which is why he's fading in some of
these early States even as he does
really well nationally and then on the
other hand we have to bid a fond
farewell to beta the time has come bra
so this is sad and when I say it's sad I
mean I'm I can't
almost stop laughing beta O'Rourke ran a
very passionate campaign started off as
like a number do you can and her and
then just dropped off the map just named
and everybody in the Democratic Party
campaign him homage they kept saying
well he's saying the stuff no one else
will say yeah yeah that and five bucks
will buy him a bad cup of coffee over at
Starbucks according to the New York
Times former representative beta
overwork of Texas announced on Friday he
was dropping out of the presidential
race ending a campaign in which he
struggled for months to recapture the
energy of his insurgent 2018 at Senate
candidacy on a national stage full of
other big personalities and liberal
champions let's be real about this
Beto's failure in this race had almost
nothing to do with made oh really I'm I
know I'm defending beta it's a thing
that's happening right now get him on
the phone and let him know the same guy
who I said if he came to my house and
tried to remove my children from me that
I would defend myself
now that guy I'm defending if the reason
I'm defending bado is because Beto's
candidacy was always media created and
now Beto's candidate is he has been
ended by the media that's really what is
going on here right beta O'Rourke was
always a figment of the media's
imagination he was imaginary he was he
was a leprechaun of politics and he was
created full-scale by the media he's
created entirely by the media roundup
and he was created that way to fight
against Ted Cruz and then Ted Cruz beat
him and then beta O'Rourke went back to
being what he was which was kind of a
loser who had never served in a position
of high politics and who was way out of
his league nationally and the media
shifted their allegiance over to
Elizabeth Warren as we will see so that
was not about beta right beta did his
best to capture the headlines he did his
best to be the guy who was speaking
truth to power right you'd be out there
saying of course I'm gonna take your
guns brah yeah absolutely
Sherman
shut down your church yeah and the media
would cheer and then they'd be like yeah
but you can't vote for him yeah but you
can't vote for him according to the New
York Times his campaign has been under
extreme financial strain or oates
advisers concluded that proceeding in
the race might have meant making deep
cuts to his staff in order to pay for
advertising and other measures to
compete in the early primary and caucus
states in just one second we'll get to
more about Pedro Rourke and his tragic
demise in this race first let's talk
about your sleep quality and I'm not
talking here about your mattress your
sheets I'm talking about like sleeping
to stay alive so there are a lot of
people in the world and in the United
States who suffer from sleep apnea in
fact my dad suffers from sleep apnea and
that means that he's reliant on a CPAP
machine to ensure that he's getting
enough oxygen to keep him healthy well
one of the problems of the CPAP machine
they're wonderful one of the problems is
cleaning them is actually kind of a pain
in the butt and this is why you need it
so clean if you're using a CPAP machine
so clean is the fast easy way to
maintain your sleep equipment so clean
maintains your sleep equipment without
the hassle of taking your equipment
apart so clean gives you the peace of
mind knowing that your sleep equipment
is properly maintained every night so
what you don't want in there is mildew
and gunk that you're breathing and so
clean is the fast and easy way to
maintain your sleep equipment it's easy
to use you just put the equipment in you
close the lid you walk away the soclean
is convenient user friendly so clean has
approximately nine thousand five-star
reviews it really is fantastic right now
for our listeners you can go try so
clean risk-free for 30 nights even
shipping is free so don't wait go to so
clean com2 take advantage of this 30
night risk-free trial and free shipping
again that is so clean calm once more so
clean calm go check them out right now
they'll make your life better it'll make
your sleep quality better make sure that
you are breathing in the cleanest air
well it is providing it the oxygen you
need to stay alive go check them out at
soclean dot-com okay so beta works
campaign basically ran out of money and
it ran out of money because he just was
not capable of drawing the kind of
attention that he drew in that race
against Ted Cruz mainly because he
wasn't running against Ted Cruz any more
and the media fell more in love with
Elizabeth Warren the Democratic primary
is really a story about who the media
decides to follow in love with so for a
moment in time Joe Biden they were never
in love with Joe Biden was the hallmark
of a-- of a bygone era right against
trump he's fine but he's really like
this oldie we don't need him elizabeth
warren she
she's somebody who makes the media
members feel really good about
themselves she's a sophisticate don't
you know she's an intellectual don't you
know we're gonna get to Elizabeth Warren
in just one second Bernie Sanders
they're leaving behind to Bernie was the
romantic pick in 2016 now they've
decided to leave Bernie Sanders behind
they decide to move on to Elizabeth
Warren and Pete booted reg who they are
also very much attached to because not
only is Pete boo to judge intersectional
right he's a gay man but Peabody Judge
is young and he's vibrant and he rips
rips on Christians on a routine basis so
when you watch the Democratic primaries
well you really have to understand is
the media have done an excellent job
picking who they want to be the nominee
for the Democrats for a brief moment in
time it was Kamala Harris and then it
sort of went away in fact I think
there's something to be said for the
idea that Donald Trump's nomination in
2016 was actually a reaction by
Republicans so the feeling that the
media had had a large hand in
controlling who the Republican nominees
were in 2008 in 2012 there was a feel
that the media had really boosted McCain
in 2008 that they had really boosted
Romney in 2012 if there were hardcore
conservative candidates who had been
basically ripped to shreds by the media
and that they were not going to listen
to the media this time around and so
they picked Trump in the Democratic
Party it's the opposite whoever in the
New York Times editorial board decides
they love that's the person who is going
to get all the benefit all of the upside
but before we bid a fond farewell
debater we have to read his thank-you
note he's written a long thank-you note
from the road rah and we would be remiss
if we did not pay this final tribute to
bado he says our campaign has been about
seeing clearly speaking honestly and
acting decisively in the best interest
of America was it though was it was it
not like you just kind of jet-setting
around being useless and saying crazy
stuff that you then had to backtrack but
then not backtrack his though it is
difficult to accept it is clear to me
now this campaign does not have the
means to move forward successfully my
service to the country will not be as a
candidate or as the nominee
acknowledging this now is in the best
interest of those in the campaign it's
in the best interest of this party as
you seek to unify around an arm and a
bra it's in the best interest of the
country and then he says that it's all
about him fighting at this campaign was
about him fighting fear by threatening
to take away your gun and destroy your
church he says I decided
run for president because i believed i
could help bring a divided country
together in common cause brought to
confront the greatest set of challenges
we've ever faced it's always funny to me
when people say things like we're
confronting the greatest set of
challenges we've ever faced our
unemployment rate is three point six
percent during the Great Depression our
unemployment rate was like 20 we are not
segregating our schools where our water
fountains we're not having a civil war
we're not having race rights against
black people in Tulsa we're not having
Vietnam War era riots really like the
biggest challenge our country has ever
faced is a guy you don't like being
president because he says weird things
on Twitter like that
that's the Democrat pitch he says I knew
that the most fundamental of our
challenges is fear the fear that Donald
Trump wants us to feel about one another
the very real fear that too many in this
country live under the fear we sometimes
feel when it comes to doing the right
thing especially when it runs counter to
what is politically convenient or
popular I know I still know we can
reject and overcome those fears and
she's instead to be defined by our
ambitions and our ability to achieve
them and it can flexes locks out of his
face and continues we should be proud of
what we've fought for and what we will
at what we were able to achieve well
you're able to achieve it is one of the
worst presidential campaigns in modern
American history is started off at near
double digits and yet ended like before
Cory Booker's campaign ended like
toastie Gabbard is Amy Klobuchar is
still running and bado is out which is
not what you would have actually
predicted and again that's because bado
was so concerned with earning the love
of the media that he forgot that that
was not a thing that was going to happen
and that what made him popular in the
first place was that he was campaigning
his moderate he made the people who
judge mistake nobuta judge has recovered
from his original mistakes Oh Buddha
judge his original mistake he came into
the race that all sorts of products was
an interesting candidate I on this show
said the people who judge was an
interesting candidate and then Buddha
judge immediately flipped into the sort
of far left crazy towns all Christians
are bad if they think that same-sex
marriage is morally a problem he moved
over there and immediately his support
started to recede then he started
attacking Elizabeth Warren and his
support started to rise again bado
jumped into the race and he was
considered sort of a moderate
alternative to Ted Cruz in Texas and
suddenly he was like I'm taking all your
guns I'm saying all the things
Democratic voters want me to say so that
is
and it failed it failed for him here's
the key he says at this moment of truth
for our country we laid bare the cost
and consequence of Donald Trump the rise
in hate crimes by the way the rise in
hate crimes is unclear whether there has
actually been a dramatic spike in hate
crimes there are more reporting agencies
so the stats on that are not clear at
all the terror attack in El Paso the
perversion of the Constitution the
diminished standing of the u.s. around
the world but we also made clear the
common responsibility to confront him
hold him accountable ensure he does not
serve another term in office committing
ourselves to this task not as Democrats
or Republicans but as Americans first
before we are anything else
so yeah baito is done and as I say he
can return back to eating what was it
New Mexican dirt after he lost to Ted
Cruz he literally went to New Mexico
picked up dirt and ate it so I guess now
he's gonna move on it's like Utah or
something no no and there are plenty of
types of dirt so bado is out so now the
question becomes who is still in now
what's been funny about a lot of this
campaign is that the person who's being
ignored more and more is Bernie Sanders
the latest poll has Bernie up in New
Hampshire the latest poll numbers have
Bernie pretty stable his health issues
are obviously a problem for him the fact
that he had a heart attack in the middle
of the campaign and he's 1 million years
old that is not helpful to him but the
media as I say because the media are
trying to dictate who exactly is leading
this race right now they've decided to
boil down this race to Elizabeth Warren
and the 4th tier candidate right the
fourth candidate in the polls
Peabody judge will get to all that in
just a second first we got to talk about
upgrading employees so as I say I just
came back from Israel and that meant it
was time to upgrade the employee base
Rob one of our producers he's been great
I mean we love Rob Rob he's great but
something about Rob just had to move to
other shows that's all I mean he had to
go work on our other shows because the
fact is we wanted to either raise the
quality of those shows or alternatively
raise the quality of our own by losing
Rob so Rob is moving on to other shows
how are we going to replace Rob let me
tell you about zip recruiter dot-com zip
recruiter com is the way that you can
get a qualified candidate incredibly
quickly with results it's no wonder four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruit to get a quality candidate
within the very first day see why zip
recruit is effective for businesses of
all sizes try zip recruiter for free at
our web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily Wire
zip recorder comm /a Dai ly Wira zip
recruiter comm slash at daily wear make
sure that your employees are the best
employees you can find don't get stuck
with somebody like rob tossing on money
or other shows and then go find somebody
else who's even better than Rob I'm not
gonna say names like Rebecca but find
somebody else who's even better than Rob
check them out at zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire zip recruiters comm
slash daily wires go check them out make
your business better and even if you're
not getting rid of somebody like Rob you
know which is a smart move instead what
you should do is you should go hire even
better employees in the future at zip
proko.com
already so as I say when it comes to the
Democratic primaries to reiterate it's
about media control they threw beta out
they brought him in they threw him out
and they were the ones who built him up
and then they tore him down it's kind of
fun to watch
I will admit well now they're building
up people to judge and mater Pete I
don't know whether he's delusional or
what the story is like mayor Pete is
actually coming out now and saying that
the race is between him and Elizabeth
Warren which is a real weird take
considering that in the national polling
here's the here's the national polling
okay the latest from from ABC News
latest national polling Joe Biden 29
sorry 27 and Joe Biden 27 Elizabeth
Warren 21 Bernie Sanders 19 Pete Budaj
age 7 in the national polling people
judges all the way down there at 7 and
yet people judge has somehow gotten the
misimpression that he is a top-tier
candidate that he's like the hot new
thing who's actually gonna challenge now
listen I know that Matt Drudge over a
Drudge Report is really high on Buddha
judges candidacy right he's been putting
Buddha judges candidacy
he's been suggesting the Buddha judge is
about to experience a wave you are
seeing some booty judge results in
places like Iowa where suddenly he looks
a little bit more competitive than he
does nationally right if you look at the
the Iowa polling right now it's got Pete
Buddha judge in second in the Real Clear
Politics poll average got Warren at 22
and Buddha judge at 17 and Biden at 16
in New Hampshire
however Buddha judge is all the way down
at 8 in those in those numbers right
it's more than 25 Biden 21 Sanders 20
who to judge 8 and then in the future
states in the further states it's it's
Buddha judge like nothing right Buddha
judge does not have any support so
basically Buddha judge is running a
strong campaign in Iowa and nothing
beyond that a Buddha judge has declared
himself the second-place candidate
basically it's between him and Elizabeth
Warren which I
as kind of smart he's posing himself as
the alternative to Joe Biden he's trying
to say that he's the moderate in the
race now that's not really true
people to judge is it radical who
pretends to be a moderate and he's quite
good at doing that because we've seen
radical blue to judge and we've seen
moderate boo to judge we've seen both of
them right he will say radical things on
foreign policy and then he will
immediately say a non radical thing on
foreign policy he'll say I'll eat a
chick-fil-a and then he'll say all
Christians are bad people he will do
this this sort of back and forth all the
time and so posing himself as the anti
Warren as the alternative to slow Joe
it's smart marketing by Buddha judge but
it is delusional for him to say as he
did over the weekend that the race is
now down to him and Elizabeth Warren I
mean the guy is he's running way behind
burning right bernie is still a human
being who exists and Joe Biden is still
your national poll leader at this point
here's Buddha judge this is this is clip
5 saying that it's down to two
candidates him and Elizabeth Warren
which is like really and so it's like me
saying that the title of best basketball
player on the planet is down to LeBron
James and me it feels like there's some
people right in the middle that you're
sort of ignoring right there like a lot
of people who are good at basketball
here is the heroes people who just being
delusional I think this is getting to be
a two-way it's early to say it I'm not
saying it is it to it but I think but do
you see them you see it's coming into
focus you and Warren yeah and certainly
a world where we're getting somewhere is
that world where it's coming down to the
two of us obviously there's a lot of
candidates and a lot of things can
happen but I think that as that happens
the contrast become clear look that the
contrasts are real their substantive
respectful policy contrasts but they're
real first of all it's interesting you
say that right so you accept the notion
right now that it's kind of worn against
the field really someone's trying to
become the alternative to Warren right
now right yeah I think it's it's shaping
up that way okay so he is right that it
is Warren against the field because the
media have truly built her up in amazing
ways the fact that he thinks that he is
the alternative and not Joe Biden is
pretty delusional and and fairly telling
it is smart of him to set it up that way
again like it's is the delusion purpose
of X is he actually believe that or is
he just posing it that way he is going
after Elizabeth Warren so Budaj edge
also suggested that like he went after
Warren's health care system proposal
over the weekend and this is what he has
been doing consistently like in Iowa the
Iowa Democratic Party had a fundraising
dinner and it turned into fisticuffs
between Warren and Budaj according to
New York Times report the Washington
Post and boughs over the Washington Post
reporting I'd say Warren is widely
regarded as the candidate to beat in
Iowa her organization is currently
judged as the best in the field her
disciplined campaign style has helped
provide the edge she currently enjoys
however Budaj edge is gaining as a
Buddha judge started slowly his campaign
initially consisted of four people his
organization was late to get moving
despite successes the candidacy of the
37 year old mayor of the city of a
hundred thousand continues to face
skepticism about its long-term
durability particularly over his ability
to attract support from African
Americans he has no black level of
support neither does Elizabeth Warren by
the way Joe Biden continues to dominate
in that category but in Iowa voter judge
has been rising rapidly of late his team
is up beat who judges sense of
confidence was on display in an
interview that he filmed that's the one
that we just showed showing that he says
that it's down to Booty judge and Morin
so he spoke on Friday night and he
delivered his thematic rationale for his
candidacy he said I will not waver from
my commitment to our values or back down
from the boldness of our ideas but I
will also not tired from the effort to
include everyone in the future we're
trying to build progressives moderates
and Republicans of conscience who are
ready for a change and then he attacked
more and directly he said we will fight
when we must fight but I'll never allow
us to get so wrapped up in the fighting
we start to think fighting is the point
the point is what lies on the other side
of the fight what lies on the other side
of that fight is the hope of an American
experience not just not defined by
exclusion but by belonging that is what
we are here to deliver then Warren got
on stage and she basically said that
Budi judge is not progressive enough
this is the problem for Elizabeth Warren
the problem for Elizabeth Warren is that
she's deeply inauthentic and that is the
big problem for Elizabeth Warren and
Buddha judge can take advantage of that
the problem for Buddha judges is also
inauthentic right sometimes he seems
moderate sometimes he's progressive
Warren is really inauthentic and her
inauthenticity is going to cost her so
she got up on stage at the Wells Fargo
Arena and she said anyone who comes on
this stage and doesn't understand that
we are already in a fight is not the
person who's gonna win that fight anyone
who comes on this stage and tells you
they can make change without a fight is
not going to win that fight anyone who
comes on this stage and tells you to
dream small and give up early is not
going to lead our party to victory this
is a time of crisis and media pundits
Washington insiders even some people on
our own party don't want to admit it
they think that running some vague
campaign that nibbles around the edges
is somehow safe fear and complacency
does not win elections hope and courage
wins elections
and so she's she's painting Buddha jej
as a sort of moderate waffling vague
person and herself as this progressive
champion well the problem for Elizabeth
Warren is that that's all fun and games
until you actually look at her plans
because Elizabeth Warren was not this
person right she's campaigning as Bernie
Sanders light and getting attention as
this progressive wonk even though she
doesn't know what the hell she's talking
about Elizabeth Warren is not wearing
well those national polls right in the
state polls she continues to do well
because the media have built her up and
cuz she has a good organization in
national polling she has certainly
receded in the past few weeks it's
impossible to miss it if you look at the
national level polling and that's
because the more she says the more
people don't like her i booty judge
again too smart to draw the contrast
with Warren he's crazy if he thinks that
there aren't other candidates in the
race but it's it's smart of him to do
this okay come on Harris for example
pointing out that Buddha judges naive
eye she's like I'm pulling Nero the same
as Buddha judge I meant like four
percent and people do judge isn't like
seven percent what the hell is he
talking about this is a two-person race
here's Komal Harris ripping into P
Buddha judge curious comments by mayor
Pete Buddha judge this weekend he's
trying to suggest now that this is
becoming a two-person race between him
and Senator Warren well I think it's
naive to think that at this point that
the debate of this election has been
determined just look at history you
might need to review past elections to
know that what's happening right now
it's not necessarily determinative of
the outcome okay so obviously you know
all the other Democratic candidates are
looking around going really is is this
the case but the problem is for each of
these candidates now has problems right
but it was promised he was completely
media dependent so he's gone Biden is
not media dependent which is why his
campaign has remained durable despite
the fact anything credibly bad at this
Warren's candidacy is media dependent if
the media ever decide that they are sick
of Elizabeth Warren she's gone she's out
right now the media may not do something
they may decide that she's the best we
have to offer and they're gonna stick
behind her even though her plans are
absolute garbage or they may shift over
to boo to judge or they could shift over
to Carmel Harris in other words this
race is still very much in flux if the
media decides to throw their support
behind another candidate if Kamala
Harris has a good debate by the way it
is beyond me why calm
is not going after Elizabeth Warren it
is an absolute fools mission not to go
after Elizabeth Warren if you are
common-law Harris and I'll explain why
in just one second first let's talk
about the underwear that currently grace
your toughest the ones on mitosis are
phenomenal I mean as I said took a
16-hour flight you know why that was
comfortable it was comfortable because I
was wearing Tommy John underwear Tommy
John are the revolutionary clothing
brand that has redefined comfort for
Americans everywhere including for me
personally Tommy John obsesses over
every little detail and stitch by using
proprietary fabrics that perform like
nothing you have ever worn before as a
result Tommy John's men's and women's
underwear Sport and no AG guarantee
comfortable stay put waist bands and a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft feather-light moisture wicking
breathable designs to move with you not
against you that means no bunching no
riding up Tommy John is so confident in
their underwear as they should be if you
don't love your first pair you can get a
full refund with their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee if you
want to go to stores they're available
in 1200 retail locations across the
country including Nordstrom's Tommy John
no adjustment any by the way great for
men great for women my wife wears Tommy
John as well supremely supremely well
engineered comfortable stuff herida
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off your
first order that is Tommy John's comm /
Ben for 20% off again Tommy John comm /
Ben best underwear you'll ever wear bar
none Tommy John comm / Ben okay so as I
say the target is now being set on
Elizabeth Warren's back and it should be
it should be like Buddha it's not a
two-person race by any stretch of the
imagination
as you'll see Bernie Sanders is still a
candidate despite the fact that Bernie
is insane and wild and crazy al Han Omar
actually over the weekend Bernie Sanders
continues to draw huge crowds like 14 15
thousand people to various arenas he did
an event in Minnesota with ohan Omar you
know the radically anti-semitism attic
awful awful human being of a
congressperson in Minnesota Ilhan Omar
actually made the pledge that Bernie
Sanders will quote fight against Western
imperialism
right like she's now promising the
Bernie Sanders is gonna fight against
America because when he'll head Omar
says Western imperialism what she means
is America being in any sense the the
sort of hegemon around the world
guaranteeing world security and safety
which has been the reality since World
War two and has basically kept the world
from devolve a into cataclysmic warfare
over the course of the last 75 years and
she's very much against this and that
means that she is Pro
Bernie Sanders here as Ilhan Omar making
the case for Bernie
who will fight against Western
imperialism by fighting against Western
imperialism she means not putting
sanctions on Turkey not putting
sanctions on Iran not putting sanctions
on Venezuela instead fighting against
Israel fighting against Europe fighting
against America's involvement around the
world to guarantee safety and security
that guy Bernie Sanders is still drawing
in third place numbers right he's still
going in the national polling Biden
Warren Bernie so all the Buddha judge
talk is a little bit early but the real
focus is on Warren and as I say her
candidacy is still vulnerable like
there's still time here her candidacy is
vulnerable because she is not in fact a
good candidate dirty little secret she's
not she no she's much more discipline
than Hillary Clinton she's less
off-putting as a human being than
Hillary Clinton also Hillary Clinton yet
people are saying she's very different
from Hillary she's mostly different from
Hillary in that we knew Hillary Clinton
we'd known Hillary Clinton since 1992
when she was pushing Medicare for all
right when she's pushing Bernie Sanders
his health care plan in 1992 and so
we've had we had 25 full years of we
think Hillary Clinton stinks like a
quarter century of everyone despising
Hillary Clinton when she ran in 2016
Elizabeth Warren is new-fangled she
she's sort of come onto the scene only
since 2008 even that was sort of a
reinvention of an earlier Elizabeth
Warren the problem is the more you see
of Elizabeth Warren the less there is to
see the more you see she's sort of as
Gertrude Stein instead of San Francisco
there's no there there when it comes to
Elizabeth Warren there's no real there
there everything she says about herself
has turned out not to be completely true
or the very least there are serious
questions to be asked about I'm talking
about everything from when I was a young
woman I was fired when I was pregnant
and that's what it's like for women and
turns out that actually they unanimously
offered to rehire her and then she
walked away or or to her native American
Schneck by the way if you think that
story is over you're wrong the Native
American hurt this is why I say Kamala
Harris not attacking Elizabeth Warren is
patently insane it's patently insane as
a campaign strategy like Hummel Harris
went after Joe Biden because she was
trying to draw the black support but the
fact is that Biden is sort of a stand-in
for not any of these other people Biden
is
his own candidate nobody thinks of Joe
Biden is like I love Joe Biden it's like
well I guess he's the alternative to
these Schmucks so I guess we'll vote for
Joe Biden so in reality
qumola should be attacking Elizabeth
Warren if she were smart and that's
particularly to run the Native American
issue how is it that we are now like
eight debates into this cycle and no one
has asked Elizabeth Warren why she
claimed to be Native American for
decades for decades like on official
forms and if you think that that had no
impact in her hiring at Harvard Law yeah
they'd say oh we've released all the
documents showing it had no impact sure
sure
she was hired right in the middle of a
massive racial scandal at Harvard Law
School in which professors like Derek
Bell were threatening to quit their jobs
unless Harvard law hired more minority
professors in and all the early press
releases
she was championed as a minority
professor she was championed as a Native
American professor according to David
French over at used to be over at
National Review so the fact is that
Elizabeth Warren has been using instance
used for 25 years 30 years
intersectional stolen Bell she pretended
she's a victim of the American society
when she is whiter than the backside of
this piece of paper right here I mean
she's supremely white and she pretended
to be a minority how has caramel hairs
not attacked her on that how's Kamala
Harris said you know some of us have
actually had to overcome racial
discrimination in America maybe she can
go back to the I was in a in an
integrated school through busing and all
of us what did you have to go through
except for pretending to be Native
American so that you could get a job and
why exactly has she never done that it's
beyond it's beyond reason and as we'll
see she could also attack her on her on
her plans like people who judge has very
successfully and to and to a great
degree of a benefit attacked Elizabeth
Warren's plans and as we will see over
the weekend Elizabeth Warren finally
papered her medicare-for-all plan and
it's completely insane it's utterly not
like everybody in the world right left
and center is looking at this plan and
going this does not square with reality
in any way shape or form which is
opening up the field for Budaj
and presumably for Carmel Harris if she
actually wanted to take that like I
think that there will be before the end
of this race another common way Harris
upswing I think the chances that the
media are happy with this super white
top-heavy Democrat field I don't think
they like it I think the media are if
Kamala Harris could actually break
through with any of this stuff I think
they'd be willing to go back to her in
absolute heartbeat but it'll get to
Elizabeth Warren
garbage medicare-for-all plan which is
just completely made up in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
when you're driving around you look
around just tons of types of car on the
road and then a part in your car breaks
you know like okay what should what
should I do now because if I go to the
local auto parts store what are the
chances they have the exact part that I
need made for this exact car I'm beyond
my warranty over at the dealer so what
should I do
well the answer is you should go check
out the interwebs and use Rock Auto calm
Rock Auto calm is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years you go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door
the rockauto.com catalog it's super easy
to navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brand specification and price
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts of your car
will ever need Rock auto comm go check
them out right now at Rock auto comm and
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about us box so they know we
sent you that helps us because then they
continue to know that we are directing
people to them and it helps them so they
know that they're spending their
advertising dollars as well and it helps
you because rockauto.com is gonna give
you great service go check them out at
Rock auto comm and right Shapiro's in
there how did you hear about us box okay
so we're going to get to Elizabeth
Warren's plan for Medicare for all in
just one second it is absolute sheer
numb and garbage it's just terrible and
everybody knows it which means that
there's still time media you could
decide to refocus in on somebody who
could actually not be a crazy person amy
klobuchar are still standing right there
Kamala Harris is more intersectional
than Elizabeth Warren and isn't a fake
minority so you could do that well get
to that in just one second first head on
over to Daly wired comment subscribe we
have a brand new app over at Daly wire
it is phenomenal you should check it out
and when you subscribe you get all the
benefits of that app that means that we
do like these live Q&A is where you can
ask me questions it's like a reddit
thread and I will answer you personally
it means that you can be part of our
mail bags that we do here on Fridays it
means that you can get access to all of
our behind the scenes stuff it means you
can get x2 all three hours of the show
daily like you love the podcast you want
two additional hours every day because
there's plenty more material where this
came from
I tell you there's a lot going on in
this head you can go check that huh
over at daily wired I come for $9.99 a
month or 99 bucks a year brings you this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler look at this cast her eyes upon
this magnificence you could have it it
could be yours $99 a year cheaper than
the monthly also it helps support us
against the nastiness of a left that
seeks 2d platform everyone they don't
like you become part of the team and
help us bring you the content that you
seek go check us out right now at daily
wire.com we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
you
all righty so Elizabeth Warren finally
releases her medicare-for-all plan and
people have been wondering you know you
keep lying about this stuff right
elizabeth warren has been asked twelve
ways from Sunday how she's gonna pay for
thirty two trillion dollars over ten
years for her Medicare for all plan and
she keeps going the wealth tax the well
taxing gonna pay for it she keeps saying
you know increases in the marginal link
no that's not gonna do it either you're
going to need to radically escalate
taxes on the middle class everyone knows
this Bernie Sanders is smart enough to
admit this publicly even people who
judge who is proposing what he calls
Medicare Medicare for some meaning men
naked Medicare for any who want a public
option even he says he would probably
have to hike middle-class taxes we even
Peabody judges honest enough to
acknowledge that here's Buddha judge
explaining that he's not gonna guarantee
no middle-class tax hike everything that
we have proposed has been paid for and
we have proposed no tax increase on the
middle class we don't have to do it in
order to deliver these health care
solutions there is a lot of money on the
table from loopholes in the corporate
tax system from the wealthiest among us
who could and should pay more and we
don't have to look to the middle class
in order to solve these problems but it
also means making sure that we make
promises we can keep okay so that is
Buddha judge basically acknowledging
he's gonna raise taxes on everybody
Warren has been the only one who says
I'm not gonna raise taxes on everybody
cuz she's a damn liar and she's
inauthentic
she's radically inauthentic she went
from school voucher proponent in 2003 so
I'm gonna eliminate charter schools in
2019 she went from I am a moderate on
issues of to income families and trying
to create solutions from them - we need
to corporate and we need to take over
every major corporation in America and
stack their board right she is she has
radically moved her positions on
everything she's deeply on authentic and
that becomes clear when you actually
dive into the details of her plan so she
releases this medicare-for-all plan and
it's just absolutely nonsense Megan
McArdle over at the Washington Post
details this she says the math is the
math for Warren's health care plan adds
up if you accept it's ludicrous premise
she says after months of pressure on
Friday Warren finally released her
comprehensive Medicare for all plan
which promises lower costs for everyone
paid for by taxes on corporations and
the rich the good news is the math adds
up as long as you buy her assumptions
the bad news is that Warren's
assumptions are crazier than keeping a
pet rhinoceros after which who cares
that her calculator works this is to
actual policymaking as the
plastic noodles in a ramen bar window is
to lunch to wit Warren says she can
deliver a generous medicare-for-all plan
with only twenty point five trillion
dollars in additional federal spending
that is a quarter to a third less than
any serious estimate of the plan from
outside her campaign how will she get
there why by slashing administrative
costs and then mandating that everything
else cost less Warren is not exactly the
first progressive performance we have
the same idea and if she pushes forward
with it she will be about the next line
in a next in a long line to discover she
can't make it work politically or
economically as Phillip Cline of the
Washington Examiner trial II noted
warned congestive as well have written
that Mexico was gonna pay for her big a
beautiful plan Lauren's revenue ideas
are if anything even more exquisitely
incredible take her proposed wealth
taxes no not the three percent ultra
millionaire wealth tax she has already
pledged but an entirely new three
percent tax on all wealth over a billion
dollars the tax Woods has warned raised
a trillion dollars over ten years the
assumption is typical of her whole plans
as Megan McArdle because on one level
math does work the US has about 600
billionaires and by my calculation the
total value of their wealth taxable
assets would be something under three
trillion dollars three percent of that
collected ten times should indeed yield
nearly one trillion dollars and another
more important level the idea is
ludicrous in terms of the tax code and
basic common sense after adding in the
ultra millionaires tax and factoring in
the other capital taxes Warren wants to
levy on financial transactions on
unrealized capital gains on corporations
we'd be asking every billionaire to hand
over more than two thirds of their total
wealth overall with over a ten-year
period if the government actually
managed to collect it their fortunes
would rapidly eroded and so with tax
collections the plan might be a good way
to smash wealth but it is a terrible way
to fund the nation's healthcare system
the best you can say for all of this is
none of this will ever happen hey
Charles Blue House over at e 21
economics 21 goes into this in more
detail he says to summarize the warren
proposal under states medicare for all's
cost as quantified by multiple credible
studies and by about thirty four point
two percent so basically she's just
saying medicare for all will cost
two-thirds of what people say it well
which is just insane it's insane
here the medicare for all proposal put
forward by Bernie Sanders is likely
wildly us to under estimating the cost
of Medicare for all why because either
you're gonna have to radically raise
reimbursement rates Medicare right now
is about 80 percent of reimbursement
rates for doctors cost hey either
they're going to have to
black male doctors into taking them in
which case many doctors will leave the
profession or they're going to have to
radically increase the rates of
reimbursement which means that the cost
is gonna be a lot higher than what
they're talking about right now another
eleven point two percent of the cost
should be met by cutting payments to
health providers such as physicians in
hospitals so in other words they're just
gonna reimburse doctors and hospitals at
lower rates which good luck with that
good luck with that
hospitals are already getting under paid
by Medicare which is why they've
radically raised what they charge
insurance companies for everybody else's
care basically if you are in private
insurance you are subsidizing Medicare
Medicare costs are lower because private
insurers are paying more money it's that
simple
approximately twenty percent of the
financing is sought by tapping sources
that are unavailable for various reasons
for example because she has already
committed that funding to other
priorities so basically she's also
double counting she's saying I took
funding used it for this but I'm also
gonna use it for Medicare for all so
then he breaks it down he says that the
cost of Medicare for all used by
Elizabeth Warren are completely insane
he says for this piece is comparison
purposes it really should cost thirty
eight trillion dollars only if we use
that number can we quantify the amounts
of savings
Warren aims to generate from provider
payment cuts so in other words she's
just making things up and then she
suggests that she is going to lower
provider payment cuts by like eleven
percent which reduced the spending from
thirty seven point six trillion dollars
to thirty three point four trillion
dollars and then the Warren campaign
memo provides a cost estimate of twenty
one trillion dollars over ten years that
is wildly out of line with the Urban
Institute which is not a right-wing
Center the Center for health and economy
the RAND Corporation and Ken Thorpe so
how exactly is she doing this my just
fun I mean she's just falsifying the
numbers she's simply falsifying the
numbers she as we say she is she's
literally double counting where she is
spending this money so even even
Saturday Night Live began to get annoyed
with this over the weekend when you've
lost Outernet live in your Elizabeth
Warren and they spend their entire time
basically on SNL is now spent with them
massaging Elizabeth Warren's political
shoulders here is SNL over the weekend
basically mocking the fact that Warren's
plans don't add up and make no sense you
said your plan would cost twenty point
five trillion but
other economists have said it could cost
34 trillion right okay let me stop you
right there and we're talking trillions
you know when the numbers are this big
they're they're just pretend
there ain't no scrooge mcduck vault you
ready to get red peeled money doesn't
exist it's just a promise from a
computer you might as well say it costs
verging none Gillian over 1250 tan same
difference
okay so SNL may actually believe that
but that's actually but it's it's true I
mean this is Elizabeth Warren's plan
she's also a tempo a of modern monetary
theory which is the idea that money
actually really doesn't exist that you
can rack up debt as much as you want and
nobody's ever gonna call in that debt so
this is the point elizabeth warren her
plans suck she herself is deeply
inauthentic she has repeatedly at the
very least fudged her past and that
means she's really vulnerable so if the
media ever decided turn out like people
are treating her as a durable top-tier
candidate I'm not so sure that's true
now I don't think the alternative is
Budaj edge I think the alternative
remains Biden because he is still the
all-purpose fill in the gap guy but it
does mean that Warren in a general is
not gonna do as well as Biden would in a
general and it means that only so long
as the media decide to continue treating
her as the front-runner will she be the
front-runner that's really what's
happened here it meanwhile this also
explains why Democrats are honing in
more and more on impeachment because if
it comes down to Elizabeth Warren versus
Donald Trump Trump is at least a 50-50
odds to be Warren because as I say she's
weak she's really weak and so the polls
show that Democrats have been doing some
heavy lifting on impeachment there's a
Fox News poll showing that 49 percent of
Americans say they favor impeachment 6
and 10 voters believe the President did
ask foreign leaders to investigate
political opponents two-thirds say that
that action is inappropriate 49% won
Trump impeached and removed from office
four percent say he should be impeached
but not removed only 41 percent oppose
impeaching Trump that is the media doing
heavy lifting right there and the
Democrats that is mirrored by an NBC
Wall Street Journal poll showing that
49% now back Trump's impeachment and
removal and then that is mirrored by
another poll this one from MSN
suggesting something similar like 52%
saying that they would like to see Trump
impeach now does that hold up over time
does that hold up over time probably not
I mean it's the top of the head
right now probably if you I'd have to
look back in the polling probably early
on in the Muller investigation you could
probably get a near majority to say they
wanted Trump impeached over that
Democrats are really pushing this hard
james Clyburn of congress he says a lot
of people i talk to you think that trump
committed treason well I'm sure that's
true I mean he's a Democrat who else is
he talking to what I'm saying is there
seems to be an indication that something
was going on here there could be high
crimes and misdemeanors taking place
there might even be bribery taking place
and we will get to the bottom of this
and then we would be able to make a
determination at that time whether or
not this something happened that was
treason this I've talked to a lot of
people since I've been home who believe
that is treasonous on the part of this
president they certainly believe some
crimes had been committed okay so the
Democrats campaign here is gonna be that
that Trump is a traitor that from
sold-out American foreign policy Trump
for his part is continuing to say that
there was no quid pro quo here which as
I say I don't think as a defense that
actually holds I think his defense
should be yeah it's pretty obvious there
was a quid pro quo I was pushing against
corruption my quid pro quo was the same
as you guys alleged Joe Biden's quid pro
quo with Ukraine was Biden was saying he
wanted a prosecutor fight like a
specific act from Ukraine he wanted in
return for releasing billions of dollars
and loan guarantees to Ukraine I wanted
them to fight Ukraine including
investigating Bereza and yeah there was
a quid pro quo but there's nothing wrong
with that and just sort of own it
instead Trump is sticking with the with
the there's no quid pro quo thing
because Trump has never given an inch on
anything even though he kind of should
because it's more of a true story Trump
tweeted out false stories are being
reported that a few Republican senators
are saying that President Trump may have
done a quid pro quo but it doesn't
matter there's nothing wrong with that
it's not an impeachable event perhaps so
but read the transcript there is no quid
pro quo again that is a that is a weird
that is a weird defense by President
Trump but in the end what this is really
going to come down to is the is the
perception as to whether this is a
political hit job and this I think Trump
does understand I think the Trump and
the Republicans do understand that just
like the Clinton impeachment didn't come
down to Clinton's actual activity right
cuz Clinton clearly about in perjury and
committed perjury
right Clinton clearly committed
impeachable crimes but that turned out
to be an unpopular move for Republicans
mainly because it was felt by the
in public that it was a partisan event
so Trump pushing that is going to be his
best strategy right here and he is aided
in that by the fact that the media are
incredibly incredibly partisan that the
media continue to push in partisan
fashion here take a perfect example
there's an article in The New York Times
today called Adam Schiff a trump
punching bag takes his case to a bigger
ring and it's a puff piece about Adam
chef when most dishonest members of
Congress who spent two and a half years
claiming the Donald Trump was in fact a
traitor who had sold America out to
Russia and would go on CNN every five
seconds he would exit his pup tent that
he had set up outside the CNN greenroom
and then go on and imply he had secret
information that would lead to Trump's
impeachment over the Moller Russia stuff
none of that ever materialized and now
he's leading the impeachment inquiry and
so the New York Times is puffing him up
Sharyl gays Stolberg and Nicholas Fehn
doze of the New York Times writing the
crowd was buzzing with Hollywood types
the actress Patricia Arquette the
producer Norman Lear at a private film
screening on Sunset Boulevard one recent
Sunday afternoon but here in Liberal
America the biggest celebrity in the
room was not someone who makes a living
in what people call the industry it was
representative Adam be shift Schiff
the straight-laced former federal
prosecutor who was on the brink of
prosecuting his biggest defendant yet
President Trump
oh the drool just emanating from the pen
of the New York Times writers by the way
you know I Adam Schiff was the biggest
person there because Patricia Arquette
isn't a very big star and producer
Norman Lear has been sort of irrelevant
for 40 in any case says these are heady
but perilous days for mr. Schiff the
inscrutable and slightly nerdy chairman
of the House Intelligence Committee who
is the leading it who's leading the
impeachment inquiry into President Trump
adored by the left reviled by the right
he's become a Rorschach test for
American politics depending on one's
point of view he's either going to save
the Republic or destroy it here in his
home district at the screening of the
great hack a film about misinformation
in the 2016 election mr. Lehrer
introduced mr. Schiff has a current
American Hero as the audience left to
its feet in a standing ovation
the congressman emerged from backstage
and standard Washington uniform navy
blazer
white shirt light blue tie his manner as
inoffensive as his attire we thank them
for their patriotism Schiff said
sombrely praising whistleblowers
including the anonymous one whose
complaint against mr. Trump prompted the
impeachment inquiry and we hope others
will follow their courageous example now
mr. Schiff 59 is the New York Times
again just
sickeningly cloying garbage er is poised
to take them
bigger stage as his inquiry moves from a
secured office suite in a Capitol Hill
basement into nationally televised
public hearings he will make the case
against mr. Trump to a divided nation in
what amounts to an epic courtroom drama
meant to unveil evidence of the
president's pressure campaign to enlist
Ukraine to smear his political rivals a
moment that is bound to be must watch TV
at home in his district with stretches
from West Hollywood to Pasadena and
north to the San Gabriel Mountains mr.
Schiff is well-acquainted with the
celebrity lifestyle he lives with his
wife Eve yes Adam and Eve oh my god New
York Times by the way it's exactly the
sort of stuff that will lead Republican
that will lead many Americans to reject
impeachment inquiry outright it's
exactly the sort of treatment because I
don't remember when trey gowdy was
leading me on crane to Benghazi this
sort of glowing treatment from the New
York Times he favors vegan Chinese food
he drives an Audi whose license plate
frame bears a line from the movie The
Big Lebowski I don't roll on Shabbos
from which he can quote at length he has
dabbled in screenwriting once drafting a
script that featured a prosecutor as the
hero he tried stand-up comedy too during
a fundraiser at the improv in Hollywood
but if mr. Schiff has a sense of humor
his friends insist he does have a dry
one he readily shows it in Washington
where he has carefully cultivated his
image as the stylistic and substantive
absence opposite of mr. Trump calm
measured reserved and brainy oh yeah
again this is I'm sorry this is this is
absurdity and it comes from the same New
York Times that literally wrote a piece
over the weekend about Trump going to a
United Fighting Championship fight in
New York and now Trump loves violence
right that's him New York Times that's
like praising Adam Schiff to the skies
they have an article over the weekend
titled it's not like Trump should have
to watch very boring sports president by
Noah Weiland the President Trump walked
onto the floor of Madison Square Garden
on Saturday night from the same corner
that the mixed martial arts fighters did
his own fighters at his side's just
below 10:00 p.m. just before 10 p.m.
Trump squeezed into a row of folding
chairs below the metal fence doctah gan
accompanied by the men who do his
battles on twitter and in congress and
found a new kind of release at a moment
of high tension in his presidency a real
blood so stitches requiring fight so the
whole the whole pieces about how Trump
loves ultimate fighting because he likes
to see people hit each other he likes to
see
but he doesn't like to be the victim of
violence as the crowd Saturday night
thrilled to the most violent kicks and
punches mr. Trump who's wearing a suit
and tie sat mostly stone-faced his arms
crossed but watching intently he loves
to reduce everything to a kind of
elemental blood level said mr. Dantonio
Trump's biographer if there's blood that
spilled and it's not his it's thrilling
to him
okay so in the end what's this gonna
come down to the impeachment stuff the
impeachment stuff is gonna come down to
do you trust the Democrats not to be
partisan hacks or do you not and if the
answer is you don't then likely this is
gonna backfire on Democrats and if you
do then likely you want Trump impeach
it's pretty obvious though the Democrats
are in fact partisan hacks and the
country is too polarized to buy into the
idea that Democrats are not especially
when led by somebody like Adam Schiff
and this impeachment inquiry okay time
for a quick thing I like and then a
quick thing that I hate and then we will
be out of here so things that I like
today so my good friends and aspirator
was on Bill Maher show and he said some
in politic things which is great which
is great he was talking about how the
left-wing repeatedly lies about America
he got all sorts of flack on it from
from Twitter which is a pretty good sign
you're doing something right as if
Twitter hates you so Prager said some
very true things on Bill Maher the
audience laughed at him but every word
that Prager says here is true
left-wing says I'll give you gigantic
lies that the United States is a racist
country this this is a lie this isn't a
gargantuan lie this is the least racist
multicultural multi-ethnic country in
the history of the world that these
people believe it is proof to me but
about how effective long ago via
Whitaker but this is an unbelievably non
racist country have you people been to
Asia do you people know that our
Japanese did not allow one Vietnamese
boat person into Japan okay cuz they're
not Japanese where he allowed them into
America
okay so Prager went off on this and he
continued right he said you know this is
this is a country where the left tells
people the men can be women and you can
see everybody getting very uptight good
for Dennis I mean really really good
stuff from Dennis Prager on Bill Maher's
show because the left has invested
itself in this idea that America is a
deeply awful terrible place and let me
tell you I was just abroad in Israel and
his rosin wonderful country great
America is such an amazing country it's
an amazing country it is a country
devoted to particular creed based on the
Constitution the Declaration
independence it's incredibly tolerant
and this is not a critique of Israel
okay it's really a critique of the
Palestinian Authority which governs over
there with not one Jew living there not
one okay the fact is that if you stack
up any country in isolation it looks bad
if you stack up America against any
other place on earth America is
unbelievably wonderful just an
incredible incredible country so good
for Denis for saying all of that ok time
for a quick thing that I hate ok so a
couple of stories that are that are just
insane so over the weekend I just want
point out the irony here over the
weekend McDonald's CEO Steve Easterbrook
step down why well because he had a
relationship with an employee and he
said it was mistake according to the
Associated Press
McDonald's chief executive officer has
been pushed out of the company after
violating company policy by engaging in
a consensual relationship with an
employee the fast-food Giants had former
president and CEO Steve Easterbrook
demonstrated poor judgment and that
McDonald's forbids managers from having
romantic relationships with direct or
indirect subordinates Easterbrook
acknowledged he had a relationship with
an employee he said it was a mistake he
said given the values of the company I
agree with the board it is time for me
to move on another reason this goes in
things I hate as opposed to things I
like I think it's fine is because the
media five seconds ago were claiming
that if Katie Hill the democratic
representative from California who was
stooping half her staff that if Katie
hill had been a man no one would have
cared what she did hey let me tell you
it is worse to lose a job as the CEO of
McDonald's than it is to lose your
congressional seat like a lot worse okay
that's a that's a way a better job and a
better paying job just to points out the
media's hypocrisy here they're not gonna
walk back any of the crap they said
about Katie Hill in the aftermath of the
head of McDonald's being forced to
resign because he had sex with a
subordinate okay other things that I
hate today this is an another
astonishing story in the gender wars
that are being fought by the left
according to the UK Daily Mail a birth
coach has now been ostracized by her
professional organization after
transgender activists branded as
offensive a Facebook post in which she
said that only women can have babies
okay ready for something super offensive
only women can have babies deal with it
deal with it only biological women can
have babies and there is no other type
of woman okay there is no other type of
woman because any other standard you set
for a woman is completely fungible and
makes no sense if you ever want to
you will doraid transgender right
activists just ask what is a woman what
is a woman because if they say it's a
set of attributes then they have now
bought into sexist perceptions of what
woman hit is supposed to constitute you
can't have it both ways
either either womanhood is a set of
attributes like how you dress and how
you act in which case I guess you're a
sexist which you reject right you say
all of these gender norms are socially
constructed or gender is not a societal
construct it's biologically based in
which case there is no case to be made
that a dude with the with the penis is
actually a woman okay but this woman
said something fairly obvious which is
that men cannot give birth by the way if
men could give birth man that you refer
a small that would be extraordinarily
painful but Lindsay McCarthy calvert 45
was forced to stand down as the
spokesperson for doula UK and has since
resigned altogether from the National
Organization for birth coaches her exit
comes after transgender rights activists
triggered an investigation in which
doula UK concluded her message breached
its equality and diversity guidelines
they did not expel the mother of four
who's been a doula for six years but
threatened to suspend her unless she
deleted at the post she did but then she
resigned believing the doula UK had
acquiesced to demands from a small
number of activists and failed to stand
up for women's rights she said I'm an
angry and sad I was effectively
ostracized for saying I am a woman and
so are my clients I've been very
disappointed by doula UK's response the
leadership are paralyzed by not wanting
to accept transgender rights activists
they have fallen over themselves to
acquiesce to their demands so what
exactly happened well the dual a UK Rose
started after cancer research UK dropped
the word women from its smear test
campaign saying instead that screening
was relevant for everyone aged 25 to 64
with a cervix I love that so the the
Cancer Research UK was telling people
women to get pap smears but then they
said well not just women can have
passengers let me tell you if you try it
on a man it's gonna be very
uncomfortable and have to come from a
different direction so that is not a
reality in response McCarthy Calvert
posted a photograph on Facebook of a
negligee GLAAD woman somersaulting
underwear with the wording I am NOT a
cervix owner I am NOT a menstruate ER I
am NOT a feeling I'm not to find my
wearing and wearing a dress and lipstick
I am a woman an adult human female
beneath it she wrote women birth all the
people make up half the population but
less than a third of the seats in the
House of Commons are occupied by us she
claimed that women were accused of
transphobia more than men arguing men
were not subjected to cries a big
and transphobia when they say they don't
want to have sex with a woman with a
penis most trans women have not had
their male genitalia removed okay now
first of all that last part is true
right if you say that a man is man or a
woman is a woman let me testify from
first-hand experience you will get an
enormous amount of flack if you're a
dude but she is right the feminists are
being basically ripped on I think if
you're a feminist and you say this stuff
you will get running out of town why
because you're perceived as a member of
the left and the left police is its own
with the with the standards of Stalin
and so she's being tossed out of an
organization for pointing out that yes
by the way women are the ones who give
birth in sanity this is the world the
left wants apparently good luck with it
all right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
but you should subscribe so you can see
the additional two hours have good stuff
to talk about I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup
is by Jessica alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
big news in the 2020 Democratic
presidential primary and I'm not talking
about baito O'Rourke's dropping out
because nobody ever actually cared about
beta or work except for the media and
they're wrong about everything I'm
talking about Elizabeth Warren releasing
the details of her health care plan
which costs roughly fifty bazillion
dollars we will get into the economics
of it and examine the broader strategy
of the war in campaign she thinks you're
a bunch of idiots check it out on the
Michael nul show
[Music]